Speaker 1: Elise Stefanik, who is an absolutely
horrible Republican member of Congress,
went on Fox News and remember, due process,
law and order, law and order, whatever they
call it these days. She went on Fox News and
said, I believe Joe Biden committed multiple
criminal acts. Really? Wow. Based on what.
Speaker 2: Evidence? And you have them trying
to protect Joe Biden, who has, I believe,
committed multiple criminal act. There's
going to come a point where they're going to
have to report on it. Absolutely. All right.
Thank you so much, Chairwoman, for coming up.
Speaker 1: Thank you. By the way, not going
to ask a question about is that due process?
Is that law and order? Elise, I believe that
the president has committed multiple criminal
acts, although I have no evidence. So let's
now dig into this one and then we're going to
really be able to say we did it. And I don't
want to hear any more from the MAGA people.
The insistence that Joe Biden is a crook is
not backed by any evidence at this point in time.
They say it to try to counterbalance documentary,
photographic and sworn eyewitness evidence
of Donald Trump's criminality. Trump is
innocent until proven guilty, but there is an
indictment based on 37 felony counts, mishandling,
obstructing, making, false statements, etc.
The Biden classified documents incident is
based on the discovery of a few dozen classified
documents, some from when Biden was in the Senate,
some from the era of the Obama administration
at Biden's former office and home.
There's a special counsel investigating it. The
special counsel hasn't finished yet. I'm fine
saying if the special counsel finds evidence that
Joe Biden did something illegal, then charge the
guy. However, that's not actually the path that
that investigation is going on. We're going to
get to that in a moment. Trump's indictment says
he was sharing classified documents, as I said,
with people who weren't authorized to see them
improperly, storing them, directing lawyers and
aides to lie and hide and obstruct and destroy.
He had toilet documents, a huge dump of documents
right by his toilet, all these different things.
Biden's document incident involves records that
were inadvertently misplaced in a locked closet at
his former office and some in his garage at home.
The White House has said as soon as we figured
that out, we immediately turned it over and
have been cooperating fully with the DOJ. That is
not what Donald Trump did. And much of what Trump
is charged with is in that aftermath. It's the
cover up for lack of a better term. Trump defied
requests, as I told you, made false statements
as I told you, told aides to hide and obstruct,
as I told you. Biden's classified documents don't
involve a single allegation of lying or a single
allegation of obstruction of justice. Why? Because
Biden didn't do those things. He's been he has
not been accused of any wrongdoing or charged
at this time. Trump's indictment could result
in prison time. We don't know yet, but it could.
Biden's classified document incident by all legal
assessments that makes sense, not by Mark Levin
or Tom Fitton, but by people who actually are
taking this seriously. Biden's consequences could
be administrative sanctions or in theory, he could
have his security clearance revoked, even though
he's president. If it finds if the investigation
finds that he was negligent or behaved improperly.
Then, of course, we have the Biden bribery
stuff. I already talked about Biden bribery
earlier. So we've now looked at Biden bribery,
we've looked at Biden classified documents,
We've looked at Hillary classified documents.
We've done it all. If anybody is found to have
likely committed a crime, I'm the first to say
charge them. But it would be wrong for me to tell
you that that's the direction these things are
pointing. Those are the facts. No matter how many
times MAGA Trumpist starts screaming about it.